Edward Schiappa: So I guess what
I'll do is I'll just go ahead
and jump in. And then by when I
when I get done with my part of
the presentation that we have
plenty of time for
q&a. So let's just jump into the
slides here. So the title here
is the transgender exigency the
role of media representation.
That's partially a riff on a
book I have coming out that is
also titled the transgender
exigenc- exigency. So the first
question I have is, why am I
using that word exigency? Well,
I like it. And I think it's
accurate because an exigency is
a situation marked by an urgent
need. And I describe the current
situation is one that because
attitudes, practices and laws
are changing rapidly,
particularly in the 2010s. And
there is an increasingly at
times vehement clash between
opposing viewpoints. And I
literally believe that lives are
in the balance. And I think that
that's one of the things I'll
talk about during the talk is
the threats of threats and
reality of violence towards the
transgender community. So I
think we are in an urgent
situation where we need to think
about the issues that I try to
address in the book, much of
what you'll hear tonight is
drawn from one chapter in
particular, that focuses on the
rise of visibility in various
forms of media, particularly in
the 2010s. So I do want to make
it clear that the scope of my
comments today, in terms of what
I mean by media, I will
delineate exactly what I mean by
that in a little bit. But there
is a broader view, if you're
interested. Here's there's a
recent issue of the
International Journal of
Communication, which is an
online journal that you can
access for free. There's a
discussion by TJ Billard, and
others that take a much broader
view of the media landscape in
terms of transgender issues. And
you can see the title there
rethinking and re theorizing
transgender media
representation. So I want to
give a quick shout out to that,
that roundtable discussion. So
the first point that I want to
make is that visibility, trans
visibility is pretty much at an
all time high. And I can say
that, in part because I'm old.
And I remember the decades of
coverage of different kinds of
issues, social movement issues,
including those dealing with
LGBT issues before we get got to
an increased visibility of the
T. So for example, in 2012, then
Vice President Joe Biden was
quoted calling transgender
equality the civil rights issue
of the time, he has said that
again since that time, the 2015
State of the Union address was
the first time in history where
a US president uttered the word
transgender in public. And as a
more recent barometer in 2020,
literally a record number of
openly transgender candidates
ran for political office. And
when Joe Biden was elected,
literally the first day in
office, he signed a number of
executive orders that dealt with
transgender issues. So
visibility is no all time high.
However, visibility is not equal
acceptance. I'm going to dive
into that, for part of tonight's
presentation. The main point
that I want to make for the next
few minutes and document the
various empirical evidence
that's available is that there
is still substantial prejudice
against trans people in the US,
may be obvious but it needs to
be laid out in a scholarly
manner, I don't use the word
transphobia. I remember in the
80s and 90s, when we advocates
moved away from homophobia, and
tried to use more precise
terminology, including simply
prejudice, Gregory Herek, who's
one of the foremost
psychologists who has done a
good deal of research on public
attitudes towards the LGBT
community also calls this sexual
prejudice rather than reducing
it to a phobia, which in some
cases is not particularly
accurate. Trans prejudice is a
term that I've heard that I
like.
So one of the earliest studies,
in fact, was by Herek and
Norton. And the data was
actually collected in 2005, even
though it wasn't published til
2012. It was a survey of 2281,
heterosexual, so pretty good
size N there for that study, and
they found some things that I
think are noteworthy. One of the
things that they found was that
the attitudes towards
transgender people correlate
with attitudes towards gay men
and lesbians. As you can see,
the correlation here is between
.66 and .84. That's not .99
however, there is some
differentiation going on. The
other thing that Norton and
Herek point out is that the
attitudes are less favorable
towards transgender people as a
category than they are towards
gay men and towards lesbians. So
the measure that they used of
that Herek has developed a
number of different scales, but
then for this particular study,
what they use is, is a fairly
straightforward and easy to use
tool called a feeling
thermometer. And this is
particularly good for short
phone interviews, where you
where you say, on a thermometer,
where 100 is the high, 50 is
lukewarm, kind of take it or
leave it in zero is as cold as
you can get. How would you
describe your feeling towards
this group, and I'm going to
show you a chart on that in just
a minute. But for transgender
people, women responded with a
36.2, which is, again,
substantially below lukewarm. So
that's a chilly reaction. And
it's even lower 27.63 for men.
So, you know, this data is now
16 years old. And we do know
that there are changes happening
in terms of attitudes towards
transgender people, but it is
one of the more thorough
studies, and therefore one that
I think still informs the
landscape, the political
landscape that we're in right
now. So here's a chart from that
study. And I'll just walk you
through it a little bit. That
top line was what I just
described you the thermometer
score for women in men towards
transgender people, you will
notice right below it, or is the
category men in general. And
notice that women scored men
more warmly than men did, right?
Women scored men at 65.71. Men
scored men at 59.03. So we're
talking even in the most
favorable categories here on
this whole chart, you know,
we're in, it's not the exact
same as temperature. But you
know, we're, we're not in high
heat of 80s and 90s here. And
you can see the score for women
in general is is comparable,
actually, both groups around 67.
And then you can also see the
scores for gay men and lesbian
women and bisexual men and
women. So it drops down but the
lowest group on this particular
chart is in fact, transgender
people. At the very bottom, by
the way, you'll see two
abbreviations there, ATG and
ATL. What that refers to are two
instruments that a Herek has
developed. One is called the
attitude towards gay men. And
the other one is the attitudes
towards lesbians. And, you know,
it is a I can't tell you what
these particular scores mean,
because I have to go back and
take a look at the article. But
but that's those are frequently
used measures of attitudes. And
in fact, in some of the research
that I'll talk about later, that
my colleagues back in Minnesota
and I did with respect to media
representations of gay men, we
use the ATG instrument to assess
those attitudes. Okay. Slightly
more recent surveys 2011, 2013,
it's interesting this top
statistic here that was found in
2011, is that less than 10% of
people said that they know
someone who is transgender.
That's significant for two
reasons. One is, as we will see,
that means that stereotypes and
media coverage are more likely
to influence people who do not
have direct real world contact
with a social group. The other
is that we're going to see that
that number has climbed
substantially in the last
decade.
There's still an acknowledgment
in these studies that
significant discriminat-
discrimination exists the HRC
survey from 2011 also use the
feeling thermometer. They report
the data in the pie chart there
at the bottom. If you add cool
with with not particularly warm
or cool, you'll see that that's
over 60%. You're about to almost
75%. And so still pretty
unsupportive attitudes when
asking in this particular form.
Now, despite this, the existence
of this prejudice and relatively
tepid scores towards the
category of transgender people,
in the last 20 years, and
particularly last 10 years,
there's been remarkable success
in many jurisdictions in
securing legal rights against
discrimination. And there's a
book that I wanted to share with
you here by Taylor, Lewis, and
Haider-Markel, called the
remarkable rise of transgender
rights. And, you know, they're,
they're quite clear, and that is
that this is a really rapid and
remarkable rise that in some
ways, bootstraps on the the
rights movements and the
successes of the gay rights
movements, which arguably
culminated in the Supreme Court
validating same sex marriage not
that many years ago. And so what
we know is that that attitudes
towards LGB is not the same as
attitudes towards T. But as I
noted earlier, they are
correlated. So there is some
related effects here. Now, one
of the things that's
particularly interesting is that
if you ask people straight up,
should discrimination against
transgender people be legal?
Most people will say, No. So
this particular prompt in this
study was transgender people
deserve the same rights and
protections of other Americans.
67%, two thirds completely
agree. And it goes up to 89%. If
you add the next group, which is
mostly agree, that's really
strong support, and you'll see
that, you know, even in the
lower categories here,
Republicans 54% agree, 32%
mostly agree that's 86%
combined. And similarly, with
the Midwest, those are the two
lowest scores. But even those,
if you combine the completely
with mostly agree, you'll find
strong agreement with the notion
that transgender people deserve
the same rights and protections.
However, that is, in part
because they are being asked the
question in more broad terms,
when you push more specific
issues, that support drops
dramatically. Or for another
example that they that they talk
about, is, you know, they will
support general rights. But then
if you ask them, will you
support a trans transgender
candidate for office, again,
support drops dramatically. Now,
there are various predictors, as
you may have seen in that
earlier, some of that earlier
data, but one of the effect let
me just go back to that for a
moment. See if I can, yeah, I
think I actually skipped over
this chart accidentally. These
are some of the correlates of
attitudes towards transgender
people. And so the column that's
important here is the one under
number one. This is what
correlates with attitudes
towards transgender people. So
the ones with asterisks are
statistically significant. Okay.
The ones without asterisks means
that was not statistically
significant. So you'll see if
you look basically from 7 down
to 11, political conservativism
means more prejudice or cooler.
Cooler temp right.
Anti-egalitarianism which is
sort of similar to
authoritarianism, I might add.
Religiosity. Gender binary
beliefs. .29, right? So you
know, you can a lot of people
today understand gender binary
well enough to say, do you? Do
you favor gender binaries? Or do
you think we should be breaking
them down? And a significant
number of people still strongly
believe and support the gender
binary binary, including, by the
way, some transgender people.
And, but what we find is that
that correlates, not as strong
as religion does. But it's the
second strongest factor on this
list in terms of predicting
negative attitudes towards
transgender groups. Okay. And
the strongest factor there at
the very bottom is that ATG
score that I talked about
earlier, meaning that if a
person has negative attitudes
towards gay men in particular,
they are more likely to have
negative attitudes towards
transgender people in general.
Okay. Alright, so. Alright, so
one of those, as you recall, was
this belief of the gender
binary. And one way to describe
that is belief in what is
commonly described as biological
essentialism. Biological
essentialism, or biological
determinism, are terms that
refer to the belief that sex
determines gender, that, and
that's genetic, right. So if you
believe that, you know, again,
to throw in the religiosity
part, you know, God made boys
and girls gave them this genetic
code. And that's what makes them
naturally feminine and
masculine. That's a belief in
biological essentialism. That,
of course, is a belief that
feminists have been battling
since the late 60s, early 70s.
Sandra Bem has a wonderful book
called the lenses of gender, she
identifies three core beliefs
that inform sexism. And this is
number one, the belief in
biological essentialism.
Similarly, studies that find
that if people are supportive of
what we call gender
traditionalism, that also
correlates with anti trans
prejudice. You know, there's
there's literally a beer
commercial that says men should
act like men. And that's an
example of gender traditionalism
being reinforced, right. A
couple studies here that support
that. I'm happy to share these
slides, by the way with anybody
who wants a PDF of them later.
And I can also provide
citations, I'm hoping that I
provide you with enough that you
could look it up yourself. But
if you want further citations,
happy to provide any of those.
So let's talk more about the
media now and the media's role.
First thing I want to recommend
if you have access to it is a
documentary that's available on
Netflix called Disclosure. And
if you remember the celuloid
celuloid closet, from a while
ago, that gave a narrative about
how gays and lesbians are just
were portrayed in popular media,
particularly fiction. This is
sort of the updated version of
that applies specifically to
transgender issues. And I think
they do A a good job with it. I
want to point out a few examples
from the early 90s. That again,
I'm old enough to remember
pretty vividly when these came
out, upper left hand well
actually start with the lower
left hand corner. This is a
highly talked about scene from
The Crying Game, where the
protagonist is about to make
love with a character named Dil,
who in this moment in the film,
Fergus realizes has a penis is a
trans woman, and responds by
punching Dil and then running to
the bathroom and vomiting. In
the upper right hand corner is
the comedy Soap Dish. The
villain of the movie is the one
yelling No, no, no here in
what's happening is on a live
broadcast of the soap opera.
characters come out and reveal
from a yearbook that in fact,
she's a transexual, as the
terminology was at the time, and
this is apparently such a
humiliating revelation that she
goes running off stage and is
plot wise defeated in the movie.
And then in the upper left hand
corner is Jim Carrey in Ace
Ventura: Pet Detective. And this
is the big reveal scene, where
again, a female character is is
revealed to be transgender. And
it is, it actually parodies the
crying game a little bit,
because one reaction that some
people have to the revelation is
that they throw up. And again,
you know, these portrayals are
examples of pretty negative
portrayals that were, most
people kind of went with the
flow in the early 90s. And
these, these movies, all three
of them were successful in their
own in their own right. And the
point that I want to make here
is if you put these things
together, his prejudice is
really bad. We're not just
talking about people saying rude
things. We're talking about real
consequences here, and want to
share some of that data with
you. So the Gay Lesbian and
Straight Education Network
reports that 75% of transgender
students feel unsafe at school
because of their gender
expression. And in the most
comprehensive gathering of data,
the US Transgender Survey in
2015, that transgender students
indicate 54% being verbally
harassed, 24% physically
attacked, 13% sexually
assaulted. Those are pretty
unfortunate statistics. There is
a meta analysis in the sense of
kind of actually a meta
literature review done by Zack
Marshall in 2019. That found
that between 2010 and 2014,
looking just at studies at
transgender, non binary and
gender diverse individuals that
there are 99 studies, or
articles exploring
discrimination, and
marginalization of transgender
people, another 47 documenting
violence and trauma. So a very
well documented phenomenon. In a
survey of just from last June
2020 1500, self identified
members of the LGBTQ community
62% of transgender Americans
reported facing discrimination
of some kind in the past year,
that would have been 2021. Two
thirds report that that
discrimination moderately are
significantly affected their
psychological well being with
roughly half recording moderate
to significant physical impacts
as well. So there's a lot of
prejudice in the media has
played a role in that. Well,
let's, let's unpack that a bit
more. But before I get to that,
one last slide here, in 2019,
again, you know, less than two
years ago, both the Human Rights
Coalition and the arguably
nonpartisan American Medical
Association described violence
against transgender people as an
epidemic. And it's not all
stranger violence, there's a lot
of documentation on partner
violence against transgender
people as well, in this
particular study by the Williams
Institute at UCLA, found that as
many as 50% experienced that
violence continues. This is a
headline from May 2021, the US
hits record for transgender
killings. And they're actually
not one but two Wikipedia pages
that are devoted to trying to
keep up with documenting these
unfortunate killings.
Okay, so there's a problem here,
and the media plays a role. And
that's what I want to talk about
two ways in which the media
plays a role. The first is
through the way the news frames
issues. TJ Billard, who I
mentioned a little bit earlier,
did a study in 2016, where he
analyzed a number of different
dimensions of language used in
media coverage, and argued that
there are certain kinds of
language that are very
delegitimizing for the trans
community. misgendering would be
an obvious example. And that
that kind of language can
detrimentally impact both the
projected legitimacy of
transgender claims, particularly
political claims, and in general
public perceptions of the
transgender community. So how
stories are framed that involve
transgender people can play a
attitude, influencing role.
Barry Tadlock political
scientist did a study that
covered over about 20 years
worth of news coverage. He
looked primarily at these
newspapers that are some
regional, nationally read
newspapers, and found some
interesting things. Most
articles about transgender
people were highly
individualistic about this
transgender person or that
transgender person. And that is
processed by people very
differently. And that's
different than a systemic or a
policy oriented kinds of
orientation. In fact, systemic
orientation only occurred in
1.7% of the articles that
Tadlock looked at. The dominant
frames that Tadlock found were
things like education, which
means educating the reader about
transgender issues, equality
claims, Liberty claims, safety
and security, which sometimes
refer to the safety and security
of transgender people. Sometimes
the safety and security fears
that people have transgender
people. Pathology, is as it
sounds, a negative frame that
describes transgender people as
having a pathological issue.
Tadlock found in about half of
the study studies, or articles
that she'd say, analyze, there's
actually pretty evident positive
or negative perspective being
proposed about half the time.
And of those 29 articles 10 of
29 were explicitly negative and
anti transgender rights. So the
media framing plays a role. Now
recall that Tadlock's analysis
ended in 2011, I think it would
be a good research project to
update that analysis. And if
anybody's interested in working
with me on that, otherwise, I do
know of some potential
collaborators across the river.
Anecdotally, I tend to notice in
the last year or so, two sort of
frames that, again, I've noticed
I can't claim empirically that
they're dominant, but one is
framing that clearly makes it a
statement that there are policy
proposals that are attacks on
transgender people. And this one
from CNN from April of this
year. He says this record
breaking year for anti
transgender legislation would
affect minors the most. So you
know, that positions transgender
people, as in this case, you
know, victims of policy assault,
if you will. The the alternative
framing that I think is also
pretty common this is this is
one from television is the more
typical, pseudo neutral frame of
It's a battle, right, the battle
over transgender rights, and
which case the news author is
ostensibly not on either side,
but is reporting that there's a
battle that kind of in that kind
of framing of course, equalizes
matters and normalizes the
conflict. So my working
hypothesis that I'd like to
explore empirically is whether
or not those in fact are
predominant frames or not.
We also know is an interesting
study that that came out this
year. That framing impacts
transgender people as audience
members as well. And here you
see the headline for yourself.
This is in a journal called LGBT
Health, negative transgender
related media message, our
messages are associated with
adverse mental health outcomes
and a multi state study of
transgender adults. In fact, in
some instances, that kind of
reaction was described as like
post traumatic stress, because
the coverage forced some viewers
to kind of relive prejudice or
attacks that they'd had to
experience themselves in the
past. The other way that media
can influence attitudes that
potentially I think is more
positive, is through
entertainment media. There's a
great deal of research, some of
which I'm going to talk about
here. That indicates that media
representation really does
matter. It's not only the if you
can see it, you can be it
coverage, which I think is also
important, but it can also
actually decrease prejudice
towards specific social groups.
And remember that statistic I
said earlier were only 10% said
they know somebody who's
transgender. We know from the
research that I'm about to
describe that the the
entertainment media is effect is
the biggest, with those people
who don't have real world
contact with those groups. So,
to to get us there, I want to
quickly recall what's known as
the contact hypothesis that
dates back to the 1950s. It's
most often credited, although
you don't think he actually
originated it, but he certainly
popularized it, Gordon Alport.
And he believed and argues in
his his 1954, very, very
influential book on prejudice,
that prejudice is fueled by
ignorance, that we don't know a
social group, and therefore we
reduce them to the stereotypes
that we've heard about them that
are frequently false and
negative. So Alport helped to
popularize the contact
hypothesis that says contact
facilitates learning about a
social group. And if you the
more you learn about a group,
and recognize how diverse they
are, and that, you know, the
stereotypes are wrong, and
overgeneralize, then the more
you can reduce prejudice. Now,
there's been six decades, almost
seven, seven decades of research
on the contact hypothesis is
been supported by literally
hundreds of studies. And the
last meta analysis, I saw I
think, had over 600 studies that
have supported the contact
hypothesis. But in the process
of articulating it, there are
certain conditions that need to
be met for contact contact, to
have a beneficial prejudice
reducing effect, there needs to
be a perception of equal status.
That's why in the Deep South,
blacks and whites had a lot of
contact. But until the Civil
Rights legislation established
equal, more equal rights, you
know, Jim Crow laws were still
essentially reinforcing the
prejudicial attitudes that many
southerners had. It helps to
have common goals, it helps to
have situations where there can
be intergroup cooperation.
Importantly, this next one
deserves sort of an extra star,
it needs to not be opposed by
authorities. And the law, which
again explains why in the south,
it took major legislation to
begin to break down the level of
prejudice and, and there of
course needs to be sufficient
contact both quantity and
quality wise to
permit people to learn about
groups and for their prejudice
to be reduced. A movie that
really nicely illustrates what
I'm talking about here is a
movie called Remember The Titans
which is actually based on a
true story in Virginia, where
they, the first year they
integrated the football team.
And both sides start off very
distrustful of the other. And
particularly the white students
were, you know, obviously in the
in majority group, and were many
of whom were pretty racist. But
the coaches eventually work
together and they create that
situation where there was the
black and white players had to
room together at camp, they had
to learn about each other, they
had to report something that
they learned about their their
roommate. And then of course,
they had the common goals have
success in the game. And by the
end of the movie, the the two
featured characters, one white,
white one, black, had become
essentially best friends. And of
course, the team was very, very
successful. But what I like
about it in particular, other
than it's based on a true story,
is that it it really does
illustrate the contact
hypothesis in the various
conditions involved with it
being met. Yeah, as I just said,
It met these various conditions.
Now, what happened in about 2005
is the development of something
that my colleagues and I called
the parasocial contact
hypothesis. Parasocial simply
refers to the fact that the
contact is not face to face, but
as mediated. And there's already
a body of literature going back
to the 50s that talked about
parasocial interaction and
parasocial relationships.
Hortman and Wohl turn that
phrase back in 1956. So what we
did was we basically smooshed
together the notion of
parasocial interaction with the
contact hypothesis, and did a
series of I think we did a total
of five or six studies that
found that people can learn
through that parasocial contact,
in ways that are analogous to
the contact hypothesis, face to
face learning experiences, and
it can reduce prejudice. So,
five of those studies were
published in, I guess it was
five studies. Communication
Monographs, the 2005 article was
simply titled The Parasocial
Contact Hypothesis. In the
Journal of homosexuality, we
published a study specifically
on the TV show Will and Grace.
And in my book Beyond
Representational Correctness, I
talked about a film class that I
talk that we found that watching
certain films decrease prejudice
towards sexual minorities. The
studies or the shows in the
communication monographs article
included Six Feet Under, and the
original iteration of the show
Queer Eye for the Straight Guy,
which was a great stimuli set of
stimuli because there are five
different gay guys on the show.
So there was a lot of
opportunity for viewers who
might not know any game men in
real life, to learn a lot about
that category. And this research
was actually the first empirical
research that documented that
prejudice could be reduced
towards sexual minorities. And
yeah, so that's the parasocial
contact hypothesis. And again, I
want to emphasize that the sort
of the amount of change depended
on prior contact. So if you had
a person who already had two or
three gay friends, their
attitudes were not changed all
that much, if at all. But it was
that group that had little to no
real world contact, and
therefore you didn't know much
about other than stereotypes.
That is the group where we saw
the most dramatic decrease of
prejudice. And I love this quote
from Gordon Alport. A
differentiated category is the
opposite of a stereotype. So
when you learn that members of a
particular social group are
actually quite varied, it is a
key cognitive step into breaking
down that prejudice. We actually
also included a study I forgot
this one this was on about Eddie
Izzard, who is a actor and stand
up comic. And Eddie in those
days, referred to themself as a
transvestite. And in a stand up
routine that we had people view
at differentiated between weirdo
transvestites and executive
transvestites, and he does this
whole thing about it being a
broader community. That's
category work. That is exactly
the kind of benefit that contact
help provides. Our research has
been out there for a while now.
It's been replicated by scholars
literally all over the world,
working on mediated contact
between a wide variety of
majority and minority
population. So as an empirical
proposition, it's it's, it's in
pretty good shape. So what does
that have to do with transgender
issues? This is Jazz Jennings,
if you don't recognize her in
this photo? Well, again, you
know, I had a picture on the
very first slide of the when
Time magazine declared a
transgender moment. We had
increased visibility,
particularly in 2015. You had
things like Orange Is the New
Black with Laverne, of Laverne
Cox, featured in it she was on
the cover of that time magazine
article I had earlier.
Transparent was hitting the
airwaves and had several
seasons. Diane Sawyer had her
interview with soon to be
Caitlyn Jenner. And there were
three new reality shows that all
featured transgender lead
characters I am Kate about
Caitlyn Jenner, I am jazz about
Jazz Jennings, which has six
seasons and becoming us that was
a one season reality show. And I
am actually not going to show
this film clip in the interest
of time.
And, but this was a an article
about Jenner's interview with
Diane Sawyer, which was actually
right before Jenner came out as
Caitlin. But it was announcing
the intention to transition and
that created quite a media
moment that is been studied are
going to turn next up. Nope,
there we go. Later that same
year is when the the famous
Vanity Fair issue came out. Call
me Caitlyn. And what there's
very interesting research that
specifically is about the impact
Caitlyn Jenner had in
particular. So, Li in a 2018
study found that news framing of
transgender issues improved
after that 2020 interview. By
improved I mean things like less
misgendering and more
sympathetic framing of
transgender issues. Study by
Patrick Miller and colleagues.
And there's a an unpublished
version in 2019, and a published
version in 2020, both of which
provide empirical support that
particularly among older
viewers, who remember Jenner, as
an Olympic athlete in 1976, I
confess that I'm in that group
that remembers that found that
that group in particular older
viewers who generally are more
conservative in their attitudes
on on issues of sexual
minorities, that gender story
was meaningful and prompted a
more empathetic response. They
found that exposure, the gender
gender story predicted reduced
prejudice and quote, following
the gender story itself, as a
form of parasocial contact may
have caused ameliorated
attitudes towards transgender
people and rights. Okay, so that
story by itself was quite
noteworthy in 2015. There were
other shows, as I mentioned
earlier, some of these
documentaries and and of course,
mirror reality shows rather. And
one of the things that Li notes
in 2021 article is that the
depiction of the site of the
transition itself the
psychological shifts and coping
mechanisms of trans gendering
with transgender loved ones
guide out-group members, that is
to say, cisgender viewers,
through the process of learning
what transgender identity is,
how to live with it, and
unlearning gender hegemony so
very much consistent with what
the parasocial contact
hypothesis would say. Learn
about the group by seeing
transgender people portrayed in
this works by the way,
regardless of whether it is
reality or fictive television
fictional narratives also have
this, this can have this
prejudice reducing effect. A
couple others that I'm going to
run through fairly quickly in
the interest of time here. If
there's a YouTube channel,
NickieTutorials, who is a
makeup, makeup in fashion,
primarily makeup, I think, I am
not an expert, but she came out
as transgender. About a year
ago, I want to say, and that
video has been viewed over 37
million times. And there is
another study that I cited in
the book that looks at YouTube
content talks about how
important YouTube content is for
transgender youth in particular,
to connect with others. There's
a study 400 viewers of an
episode of Royal Pains, which is
a dramedy that is not ostensibly
about transgender issues, it's a
medical dramas. But there was an
episode where a transgender
character was central. And they
found that even a single episode
with a relatively brief
storyline can infer the
influential for decreasing
prejudice. And that was a study
that was published in 2018.
Visibility and representation of
transgender people and TV is up
you see two examples here of
Nicole Maines and Supergirl, who
she is transgender, and she
plays a transgender character.
And on Grey's Anatomy, I don't
know I don't watch the show. But
this character was on there for
a while. I don't know if he's
still on there. But Alex Blue
Davis, again, a transgender man
playing a transgender man. So
representation is increasing.
As I mentioned at the outset,
visibility can be a double edged
sword. On one hand, we do know
that prayer, social contact has
the potential to decrease
prejudice. On the other hand,
remember those conditions that
our ports, subsequent research,
so all the hundreds of studies
that were done on the contact
hypothesis demonstrating
opposition from a salient
authority can mute or moot the
impact or some or all of the
impact of positive pair social
contact, if it is opposed by a
salient authority figure. So and
we just had four years of that
right. We had pretty pro the
emergence of pro transgender
issues in the in the at the end
of the Obama administration in
particular You know, and that
came under a crashing halt under
the Trump administration. And we
now find various Republican
politicians taking pretty anti
trans positions that matters
study just published in 2020,
here by Jones and Brewer,
basing, they're doing a study of
data from 2015 16 found that
politically aware citizens tend
to follow their elite cues along
ideological lines. In other
words, it matters if the head of
the Republican Party takes an
anti trans position, and the
head of the Democratic Party
takes a pro trans position. That
is a doesn't have to be
translated that way. But the
fact is, that it is it is for
many people. And that's why they
conclude that the future
trajectory of public opinion on
transgender rights with us seem
to depend significantly on the
behavior of elites, okay. And,
in general, yeah. So I'm going
to have to look at the chat
stuff when I get done. But I
promise I will do that at that
point. So in general, what's
happened with transgender issues
is that they become the latest
front in the so called culture
wars. There's a recent just last
week, column by Judith Butler in
The Guardian, where she
describes what she believes is a
worldwide effort to quash LGBTQ
in general, with transgender
issues being sort of the wedge
issue, if you will. And she says
the attacks on so called gender
ideology have grown throughout
the world stoked by electronic
networks and backed by extensive
right wing Catholic and
evangelical organizations. And
we might add in the US, in many
places, the Republican Party.
And her point is, is that, you
know, even those these efforts
may be in terms of their
leadership, nationalistic,
transphobic, misogynist, and
homophobic. The aim, they
believe, is to reverse
progressive legislation that has
been won over a period of
decades, decades of progress by
the feminist movement and LGBTQI
issues. And there's a link to
her article from last week in
The Guardian, you find it pretty
easily by looking at that date,
October 23. So it's definitely
been activated. I'll give you a
couple of quick examples. There
have been efforts in some states
to deny medical care for
transgender minors, particularly
puberty blocking, or her hormone
therapy drugs. The red states
are states that are have either
passed it or considering passing
it. Another example is dealing
with bathrooms in particular,
you'll see that North Carolina
is no longer red. It was
actually one of the first states
that pass such a law. But there
was so much backlash to it that
they largely have backed off of
that with the election of a
Democratic governor. But you can
see there are some states that
are green, that means that they
actually have passed legislation
to protect transgender peoples
from being discriminated against
for bathroom access. And some of
those laws have actually been on
the books for years and years
now. So we actually have a lot
of empirical data showing that
there's no harm done. And we do
still have some conservative
states there that are
considering or passing. There's
actually a number of states
where this has been proposed,
but relatively few where it has
passed so far. Sports is a
particular hotspot, there have
been I think, 10 states now that
have passed laws, that they that
in public schools that forbid
they're primarily aimed at
transgender girls competing with
on the girls teams. You can see
these are all sort of
recognizable as fairly
conservative states. South
Dakota was a state where the
governor actually vetoed the
law, but then did very similar
things through executive action.
Texas, Governor Abbott just
signed that that law this in
this past week, there are other
states including Massachusetts
and Connecticut, that have the
opposite kind of laws that
specifically protect students
access to sporting teams, based
on gender identity. So it's
definitely a flashpoint going on
right now. And that's what
essentially led to this book,
the transgender exigency
defining sex and gender in the
21st century. This is the book
that I started on as my pandem-
Actually, I started before the
pandemic, but basically have
written over the last two years,
it's going to be out in
December. What I've talked about
today, in terms of media is
mostly stemming from chapter
three of that book, what the
rest of the book looks at, are
these controversies over how sex
and gender should be defined in
context, specifically, that have
been traditionally segregated by
sex slash gender, including
single sex schools, bathrooms,
the military, sports, in
prisons, obviously, I don't have
time to talk about those
tonight. But those are, that's
what makes up the bulk of the
book. And so what I try to do in
those case study chapters is
understand the history of sex
segregation in a particular
context, because they have very
different historical roots. And
thereby, try to identify what
are the values and interests
that competing definitions
represent. And in some cases,
the value is plain misogyny, or
sexism, and in or were trans
prejudice in the case of the
military. And so that's what I
tried to do is unpack in each
chapter, what the values are
that underlie competing the
competing definitions in there.
So I, I'm going to skip over
this, this was gonna, I was
gonna talk a little bit about
the bathroom chapter. But since
it's already six, I'm going to
I'm not going to do that. But
what happened in that case, just
as you can see here is that the
bathroom, the ordinance simply
said, Don't you can't
discriminate against people,
based on gender identity, turned
into Oh, this is a law that's
going to let men use women's
bathrooms. And that's a threat.
And that was what the whole
campaign was, that ultimately
ended up reversing that Houston
City Council ordinance. And I'm
not going to show you the ad. On
the other hand, this is one of
my favorite visual arguments on
the other side. This is Michael
Hughes on the right, trans man.
And when this was all hitting
the airwaves a few years ago, he
had a series of photos like of
this of himself in women's
bathrooms, these are friends of
his that are helping him make
the photograph to show how
absurd it would be to require
him to use the women's restroom.
As I said, the battle
particularly in bathroom bills
is far from over. It turns out
that the latest surveys are
indicating that a growing number
of people are actually
supporting restricting bathroom
access. I think that goes back
to the fact that those they're
getting their cues from certain
political elites with whom they
want to identify. And this is a
headline from just September 29.
Featured about a month ago. Most
Americans generally support pro
LGBTQ policies, as I documented
earlier, but are getting
increasingly divided over
specifics, such as transgender
sports and bathroom policies.
And that's a study that was
recently released by the Public
Religion Research Institute.
There's their link, if you want
to take a look at the study as a
whole. We do know, by the way, I
just want to say that the
empirical evidence makes it very
clear that there is no threat in
these bathrooms. There are
jurisdictions that have had
bathroom bills on the books for
years with no problems. On the
other hand, we do know that
there are substantial
psychological and physical harms
that are imposed on transgender
people when bathrooms, bills are
passed. And that includes
everything from increasing rates
of UTI, for people having to
hold it too long, to physical
violence, and increase suicidal
ideation as documented by CME
and study in 2016. So pretty
clear call in terms of what the
relative harms of the two
definitions are there. There's a
wide range of what I call
regulatory definitions, that is
definitions that regulate who
counts as male or female man or
woman in a particular context.
They range from single sex
colleges that only require like
Wellesley only require you to
say I'm going to live my life as
a woman to be eligible to apply
for admission. Others want a
matching birth certificate. So
even in single sex colleges,
there's the variety, sports is
another example I gave you.
There are 10 states that now
have a biological essentialist
definition of sex, where there
there are a fewer number of
states on the other hand that
allow self identification as the
means of defining gender for
sports purposes. The same is
true with jails and prisons,
there are states that require
that you go to the jail that
your birth certificate says you
belong in, and California,
Massachusetts, and there's at
least one of their state are
trying to empower self
definition for being a
presumptive, not necessarily
final, but presumptive means of
assigning whether you go to the
men's or women's facility. So to
cut to the conclusion of the
book, basically, I argue that
look the more onerous
definitional criteria, with, you
know, the surgery being the
highest demanding criteria,
which the Olympics require, if
you want to compete in sport,
outside your assigned birth,
sex, with self identification
being the the least restrictive,
that the more you move up that
that ladder, the more compelling
and powerful the rationale needs
to be. The book is, as I said,
it's coming out actually in
December 17, I want to give a
shout out right here to MIT
Libraries, thanks to a generous
grant from them, the book will
be available open access. So if
you don't want to buy it, you
don't have to, you can download
it, I believe it will be like a
PDF that you'll be able to
download. And that'll be on
December 17. And maybe, maybe
sooner, but probably December
17. I've also referenced a
couple times in this book. The
other books and articles that
I've done that are relevant to
this talk on the parasocial
contact hypothesis. The previous
book I did on pragmatic
approaches to definitions is
called Defining Reality. I have
all this in PDF form. And if
anybody would like a copy, I'm
more than happy to share that
with them. And there is my email
address, just my last name @
mit.edu. And you can see some of
my early gender socialization
going on there with the way my
parents dressed me on the left
hand side there. So I'm going to
finally end it there a little
bit longer than I meant to be.
And I'm going to turn it over to
whatever questions we have time
for in the remaining minutes of
the of the talk.
Heather Hendershot: Thank you,
Ed. This is Heather on oops, I'm
in the dark. Hi, I apologize for
missing the very beginning, I
had an unstable internet signal
and everything went to hell in a
handbasket. But I'm on my hot
spot on my phone now. So I
should be fine. I wanted to make
two very, very quick comments
and ask two questions just to
kick us off. For the comments. I
just wanted to say especially
for some of the younger folks
out there watching this talk,
that this this argument about
the dangers of different sexes
being in bathrooms, goes back to
the ERA, of the Equal Rights
Amendment. And we were talking
about Phyllis Schlafly in my
grad class, just the other day.
And so I just wanted to, like
fill people in that like this as
a kind of crisis rhetoric has it
has a history going back, I
would say to at least the 70s
and I it just fascinating how it
just sticks.
Edward Schiappa: I interrupted
for just two seconds because I
have a bathroom related comment.
So if you've ever used the
restrooms in building 14N,
right, where CMS/W headquarters
are, yeah, the women's room on
the third floor is much nicer
than the men's room. And there's
an interesting, sexist history
behind that. Because laws
requiring bathrooms to be
separated by sex are actually
not all that old. They're
actually only emerged in the
late 1800s. And a lot of the
rationale for having separate
bathrooms was based on this
idea, not only a privacy, but of
protecting women. Yeah. And
that's why a lot of women's
rooms are on there. Sometimes
they're called lounges even that
there's an extra couch in there
things of that sort. And not
every place, of course, but in
many places, and that actually
has its historical roots in this
sort of differential treatment
between of the sexes with, with
bathrooms. Yeah,
Heather Hendershot: that's an
interesting point that these
spaces for women are treated as
kind of aesthetic spaces, in
some ways the place to fix your
makeup and that they're treated
as utilitarian spaces when
they're targeted to men. So
yeah, thank you for filling us
in on that. My other comment was
about just quickly about Caitlyn
Jenner that she is you know, are
very aggressively pro Trump
supporter. And so it's just it's
a, it's ideologically sort of
incoherent to me and speaks to
some of the complications, what
you're saying about the
importance of authorities, and
how that influences attitudes.
My questions, were first about
Disclosure, which I will watch,
I'm very glad you drew our
attention to that. And I'm a I'm
a, I've seen the Celluloid
Closet several times. And I also
recommend that to those who
haven't seen it, and one of the
most fascinating things about
the Celluloid Closet is that the
focus is relying on interviewing
people who wrote for Hollywood,
in the 50s, and 60s, and maybe
the 70s. But it's really that
that earlier era, and you get to
see people behind the scenes
talking about, you know,
something that seemed like [...]
against the grain when you saw
the film, and they're like, oh,
no, we totally meant that to be
about gay people, or Yeah, camp
is not a, you know, a hidden
thing. It's what we were doing,
because we wanted to express
ourselves. And so, so it's the
behind the scenes stuff in that
film is really fascinating. And
I'm wondering if, if Disclosure
gets into that at all, or if
you've just thought about the
role of trans people as
producers, as opposed to just on
the representation side of the
equation. And my other question
was also about rep is more about
representation. And just if
you've thought about or seen any
studies, about trans people
appearing in media or in
television, say, where it's not
an issue, it's not a very
special issue about trans but
just you know, you have a trans
actor like saying that in the in
the Queen's Gambit where it's
not discussed, it's just sort of
there. And this, of course, was
a tactic for African Americans,
in particular, in the 60s, of
just sort of casually
incorporating African Americans
into cast and not making it an
issue that had to be discussed.
So those are my two questions.
All right. And also, I didn't
say this, but thank you very
much for your talk, I should
have opened with better
Edward Schiappa: Let me address
those questions in reverse
order. So I don't forget the
second one, for a representation
to have the possibility of
decreasing prejudice, the viewer
must recognize that that person
represents that group.
So even if it's not, it could to
answer your question. It could
have a positive effect, as long
as the viewer recognizes, oh,
that's, that's a trans woman, or
that's a trans man. But if if
it's not called attention to in
the narrative of the show, then
it depends on how savvy the
viewer is. Right? So you know,
that they do, on the other hand,
with African Americans, you
know, or certain other groups.
And again, people are not
necessarily fine grained. Right,
then what I mean by that is,
most people are not, this is
there's a long history here of
Japanese people portraying
Chinese people, and you know,
but they get grouped under
Asian, which means Asian
representation, tends to end up
being a more holistic set of
attitudes. So anyway, yes, I
think actually, the more
normalized it is to have trans
people in a narrative, the
better, but it won't reduce
prejudice unless viewers
recognize them as trans. And
then to go back to the point
about disclosure particularly,
or we Celluloid Closet,
disclosure, I think, I think
they learned some lessons about
Celluloid Closet. What I mean by
that is it ends on a more upbeat
note that I recall, Celluloid
Closet ending, which is, you
know, I mean, the basic
narrative is, here's all these
horrible, horrible, horrible
representations, you know, which
is not a shock. And but devoting
a non trivial amount of time
towards the end of the
documentary, documentary, noting
progress in some of the some of
the shows that I've talked about
before, and the issue, I
believe, of trans writers being
in the writing room is also I
think, that's also talked about
if my memory is correct. I, I
know, I certainly am aware of
that discussion being taking
place, but so I hope I answered
your questions.
Heather Hendershot: Yeah, thank
you. That's very helpful. Um,
let's, let's open up. We could
go to we have a few things
actually in the chat if we want
to take a look at that. Or
actually, maybe we have actual
question fully fleshed out in in
the q&a here. Thanks for a great
talk. This is from Tom Sca-,
Scahill your example supporting
the parasocial contact
hypothesis involved visual
representations. Do you know of
any studies that discuss the
efficacy of non visual media
written and maybe even strictly
audio media such as podcasts, or
parasocial contact changing
attitudes towards trans people.
Edward Schiappa: And Hi, Tom,
first of all, secondly, yes, as
a matter of fact, I've got the
cards. And I don't have the
sites memorized, but they are
cited in my chapter three of my
book. And I'd be happy to look
up their sites, but they
included, like, short stories.
And obviously, the portrayal has
to be not negative, right? You
can't have a trans character
who's the villain and expect it
to change attitudes in a
positive way. But sympathetic
portrayals and even relatively
short vignettes, you know, like
a few paragraphs about my
experience as a trans person
found, and again, when we talk
about changing prejudice, I want
to make it real clear, it
doesn't mean real. Like that.
It's not necessarily 180 degree
turn. But that's okay. Because
what the research on prejudice
reduction shows is that you do
work by stages. If you can get
the foot in the door, and get
people away from highly negative
attitudes, then they're more
likely to actually maybe
interact with a transgender
person in real life, boom, you
move the dial a bit further, or
the watch a show that, you know,
it has transgender characters
boom, little bit further. And so
these things can can build on
each other. But it really is
interesting. I haven't heard
anything, any research about
podcasts. But I would think that
the logic would be the same if
you are learning about a
category of people with whom you
do not have real world face to
face contact. Yes, mediated
contact, if you learn about the
group, and its positive
representation, can reduce
prejudice. The way we
operationalized positive
representations in our studies
was we had a series of measures
that we did about how people
felt about straight characters,
the main straight characters, as
well as the main gay characters.
And we wanted to make sure that
people were not seeing them
substantially. Inferior,
negative to those.
Heather Hendershot: That's
interesting what you say about
negative characters, because of
course, negative characters can
be written such that they are
incredibly appealing. So you
know, I would just wonder if
it's a kind of victory for a
subjugated group, when they when
having a negative character from
that group is no longer
problematic in the way it was.
Earlier, I was thinking of like,
Giancarlo Esposito and
the Mandalorian, right. He's a
villain and he is probably, you
know, one of the very best
characters on the show. But if
that character, that type of
character in the 60s would have
seen been seen, as you know,
very problematic, perhaps can
compare to now.
So I see Sulafa as her hand up.
You'll need to unmute.
Sulafa Zidani: Oh, hello.
Thank you for your talk. A
really interesting topic. I
actually have a follow up about
the parasocial relationship. And
I'm mainly thinking about like
how many of us now practice
binge watching a show rather
than like watching once a week.
And I haven't really studied
parasocial relationships. But my
hunch tells me that that might
form like a different type of
relationship to a character
where we've entered an entire
season in a day or two, rather
than like, Wait weekly to meet
with them. Do you? Do you think
that that might have a different
effect? Or have there even been
studies about that?
Edward Schiappa: I think there's
actually been one study on that.
And I have to do a little
digging to find it.
Not so much that the study was
on. It was not necessarily about
prejudice reduction, but it was
about the kind of parasocial
relationship that you might have
with characters. We do know, for
example, that when that people
respond, psychologically
speaking, similarly to the loss
of a beloved character, in not
unfamiliar ways as they would
lose when they lose somebody in
real life, there's, there's
grief involved. And and there
are, you know, I miss that
character kind of reactions, and
I do or I either I think I read
maybe reviewed a study I don't
know if it's in print yet, but I
think I reviewed a study that
was trying to address this very
issue about a periodic
experience of a show versus
binge watch binge watching. And
I think that it's the periodic
watching that builds sort of
grows deeper roots. I mean, you
binge watch your it's like The
difference between getting
drenched in a drip drip drip
effect over time. drip drip drip
is actually will have a bigger
long term impact because you'll
remember it in memory is where
these reactions live. Whereas
binge watching, you know,
whether those attitudes that are
encouraged by by spending a
couple days deeply invested?
Well, those last over time.
Depends how much you like if you
go back and re binge, you know,
which some of us have done
during the pandemic. Rewatch the
series we've already seen, you
know, that's a good way to dig
the roots in deeper as well. So,
I hope that answers your
question. As I said, I know I
read a study on that. I might
have been a reviewer at the time
to check to see if I can figure
that out.
Heather Hendershot: Thanks, Ed.
We have a question in the q&a
from Karl, how do you think
about, excuse me, how do you
think about or account for the
backlash effect of increased
visibility?
Edward Schiappa: Yeah, I
wouldn't take advice Tucker
Carlson offered on anything. But
he's got millions of people who
do and the guide is anti trans.
And that's going to influence
viewers. So I say Ámbar has a
question. So let's go to her.
Ámbar Reyes: Thank you. For you,
Ed. It's fantastic. I have a
question.
Do you have a sense about how
reception or prejudice might
change if we are the issue of
like race and class to trans
people in media representation?
Edward Schiappa: Absolutely. And
thank you for raising that I do
address the issue of
intersectionality. In the book,
I did not so much, obviously, I
didn't mention those terms
today. Yeah, I mean, the most
vulnerable group and the group
that is victimized and the most
violence against our black trans
women, that is the group that
are for lack of a better way of
putting it murdered, the most of
all trans of all trans groups.
And that's because within
certain cultures, they're,
they're violating the norms that
are expected by some who believe
in those gender binaries. And
so, again, I think that that's
why you know, in the book Beyond
representational correctness,
one of the points that I make is
that there's no such thing as a
perfect representation, just no
such thing. There is also no
single representation that's
going to solve a problem of
prejudice. So the solution is
more and more and more and
diversity. And so if you want to
reduce prejudice towards trans
people, then you need to have
trans men as well as trans
women. And you need to have you
know, Hispanic trans women,
Hispanic trans men. And you need
to have, again, the full
spectrum because it is
intersectional there's a HBO
show called we're here that if
you have not watched I encourage
you to try to catch it if you
get a chance to it's aired on
HBO and then you if you miss
episodes, you have to go to HBO
max to view it, which I'm not
real fond of, but and it's
mostly about it it's a it's a
show about three drag queens who
go to bless their heart, you
know, conservative rural areas
and put on a drag show and Take
three people who are in the
LGBTQ community there who
participated in some cases, and
they're very dramatic stories.
Some of those stories are
transgender stories. And they
are also pretty diverse stories
because of where they travel,
the episode that I just recently
watched. They were in Del Rio,
Texas. So there was a added
dimensionality of people who
live on the border, and who have
Hispanic background and Latino
background, Latino background.
So that's I don't know if I've
answered your question. It is it
is an important added dimension.
Absolutely. And I do discuss it
some in the book. And I have a
chapter actually on how feminism
is wrestling with issues of
transgenderism. And that's a
place in particular, where I do
a quick call back on the history
of the rise of intersectionality
as a important topic and
feminist theorizing in
particular.
Ámbar Reyes: Thank you.
Heather Hendershot: Um, do we
have any other questions? I'll
look at the chat says,
from Narbal. Brilliant,
professor, always pretty good to
listen to you and your
reflections. I would love to
hear you talking about the
possible connection between pch
and human rights. Greetings from
Brazil.
Edward Schiappa: Hi, Narbal.
Nice to see you. Or, nice to
hear from you.
Yeah, so the part of the problem
of answering this is something
I'm going to limit myself to
narrative media programming.
That is to say, whether it be
reality or fictional, they're
both narratives. And that means
they have recognizable
characters. And what television
and film are good at, is evoking
an emotional response between
viewers and characters. Again,
whether those characters be
fictive or real, not so good
with more abstract philosophical
concepts like human rights. So
what that means is, is that you
could get sympathy for a group
of people that may be related to
the fact that their rights had
been denied. You betcha. You
betcha it can do that. But what
we found was we did we did a one
of the research projects we did,
we wanted to see if if a class
devoted to masculinity changed
anybody's attitudes about
masculinity. And in particular,
how they saw themselves whether
they're biologically considered
male or female on birth or not,
whether their attitudes about
their own gender norms was was
changed. No, people did not get
into the abstractions, nor were
they willing necessarily to
change how they would describe
themselves. What it did do,
though, is again, it provided
elicited a sympathetic response
with the characters that they
saw. So it reduced prejudice
against gay men against
transgender men in this we have
a film that featured that
against drag queens, so they had
a sympathetic response with the
characters. But that doesn't
necessarily translate to broader
political abstractions. I wish
it did. I wish it did. It's hard
to do systemic critique through
narrative media.
Heather Hendershot: Well, we've
just about hit 630. But do we
have one last question before we
sign off?
Edward Schiappa: Thank you,
normal normal for joining us.
Professor from Brazil, great
guy.
Heather Hendershot: Well, that's
great. Um, okay. Well, I think
we will stop there, then. Thank
you again, Professor Schiappa,
for your talk. We really
appreciate it.
Edward Schiappa: You betcha. And
I'm putting my email address one
last time in the chat box for
those who are on Zoom.
Otherwise, it's just my last
name schiappa@mit.edu. So if
there are any sources that I've
described here, that you would
like more information about any
of the publications that I've
discussed. Just reach out
Heather Hendershot: and we will
also have a recording of this
available shortly. So if anyone
wants to revisit any of the
slides or the citations, you can
also do it that way. Okay,
great. Thank you.
Edward Schiappa: Thank you.
Heather Hendershot: Bye,
everyone.